et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Florence Portelli bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vice-présidente des
républicains maire de taverern dans le
valdoise et auteur de ce livre dont on
va parler avec Stéphane Fran parl c'est
aux éditions du SER et on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté justement ce matin par
Stéphane Vernet de Ouest France bonjour
Stéphane bonjour Oriane bonjour madame
por bonjour bonjour bonjour on va
d'abord parler du remanement de la suite
du remanement du gouvernement Atal qui
est attendu dans les prochaines heures a
priori est-ce que vous redoutez de
nouveau débauchage chez les républicains
euh écoutez la seule chose que je
redoute c'est qu'on est toujours pas de
ministre du Logement alors que c'est une
crise majeure dans notre pays et
peut-être un des points
fondamentaux de ce qu'il faudrait
réformer sur lesquel il faudrait avancer
qu'on est toujours pas de ministre de la
Fonction publique on n pas de ministre
des outres mes enfin voilà ça c'est des
vrais sujets les personnes après je vous
avoue que je ça m'intéresse pas beaucoup
mais vous redoutez pas qu' il y a eu
Rachid adati dans la première vague
est-ce que vous cigz qu' en a d'autres
d'A je ne crains rien du tout je veux
dire vu l'état de délabrement moral et
sur les idées de la classe politique
française c'est pas craindre c'est
constater et avec beaucoup de distance
c'est pas mon sujet mon sujet c'est
comment on va avancer sur les sujets
majeur dont don je vous ai parlé je
trouve extrêmement grave que depuis la
nomination de Monsieur hatal il n'y ait
toujours pas ces ministr nommé on va en
parler on va parler de ces sujets parce
que vous en parlez dans votre livre mais
quand même est-ce que il y a pas une
volonté vous sentez pas une volonté chez
Gabriel Atal chez Emmanuel Macron
d'affaiblir votre parti ah écoutez moi
je suis pas dans des logiques partisanes
donc c'est vrai que je me sens très
étrangère à à tout ça ce que je constate
c'est que c'est des gens qui
déconstruisent beaucoup et d'ailleurs
avec un jeu assez cynique depuis
l'arrivée de Monsieur Macron au pouvoir
en 2017 ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on n
jamais eu des partis au frange de
l'extrémisme on va dire ça poliment
aussi près du pouvoir donc voilà il a
réussi il a réussi ça et en même temps
si je puis dire il n'a rien réussi à
construire et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il a abandonné en
grande partie ces ces théories enfin en
tous les cas ses appartenances les plus
à gauche ses alliances les plus à gauche
qu' sent en ce moment sur la droite avec
des slogans parce qu'après on pourra
reparler du fond parce que le pays
penche à droite mais ça c'est pas une
vision c'est n pas un une pensée ce
n'est pas une vision idéologique pour le
pays c'est du casting c'est de la com et
on est aujourd'hui dans une société de
la com que ce soit monsieur hatal
monsieur Macron ou même monsieur
Bardella c'est des gens qui présentent
bien vous mettez sur un plateau c'est
des phrases courtes c'est rapide c'est
lapidaire ça ça fait joli sur le papier
et quand on gratte bah là il y a un vrai
problème de fond et ça c'est assez
effrayant et moi je suis ravie d'être
sur votre chaîne parce qu'en général les
débats sont sont poussés notamment vous
avez des émissions qui sont quand même
des des émissions d'approfondissement on
peut pas dire que ce soit le cas partout
Stéphane à votre avis pourquoi est-ce
que ça a été si long pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu autant est-ce que ça
avait un lien par exemple avec la
décision de justice sur l'affaire du
MoDem hier écoutez ça j'en sais rien
mais je pense aussi que c'est parce que
tout simplement pour eux ça n'a pas
grande importance le fond n'a pas
d'importanceon c'est la forme on peut
attendre la preuve c'est qu'on attend
alors on va attendre jusqu'à un certain
point puisqu'il y a une règle concernant
la le fait que quand vous quittez un un
poste de député ou de sénateur je crois
que vous êtes limité dans le temps pour
que ce votre supplant puisse prendre vot
place voilà un mois donc ça ser
c'estàd en fait par exemple sur la
question lave la grave crise du logement
de se dire bah là on on a pris des mois
voir des années de retard mais c'est
tout simplement on est dans une histoire
de d'arrangement politique par rapport à
des à ce type de problématique question
d'en freran parler dans votre livre vous
vous reprochez à la droite d'avoir
laissé à la gauche des thématiques
fondamentales comme la culture
l'éducation ou l'écologie alors sur
l'éducation qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des dispositions annoncées par Gabriel
Atal quand il était ministre de
l'éducation nationale là on n pas dans
un dans le registre de droite alors dans
dans le registre c'est menti la droite
après ch c'est que stique il a pas eu le
temps
d'allerdiction la c'est oui
l'interdiction de la BAA même si je
pense que sur la BAA on ne va pas
jusqu'au fond du discours c'est c'est
pas simplement une histoire de laïcité
moi je vous dis très sincèrement en tant
que femme politique c'est quelle est la
vision de la femme en France et dans un
pays occidental je suis désolée c'est
pas l'asservicement par le vêtement en
tout les cas dans la sphère publique
donc moi je P cette position là
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme c'est
concret expériimentation de l'uniforme
je suis pour et je l'expérimente dans ma
collectivité on a candidaté mais c'est
une disposition proposée par François
Fillon en 2017 donc en réalité il y a
rien de nouveau al vous allez me dire
bah c'est bien lui il le fait très bien
mais il n'y a pas que ça faut aller
beaucoup plus loin que ça Jacob l'avait
expérimenté dans sa ville de province
oui mais la la question des savoirs
fondamentaux la question de de
l'émancipation intellectuelle de la de
la capacité à réfléchir des enfants à un
âge très petit c'est ces questions là
qu'il faut poser la question aussi de
Laib ces questions là non non mais il n
il n'a rien proposé là-dessus il y a
tout un plan choc des savoirs qui a été
détaillé par Gabriel hatal quand il
était encore ministre deéducation
nationale il ça ne va pas assez loin la
question aussi des de la de l'autonomie
des chefs d'établissement un directeur
d'école aujourd'hui n'est pas un chef
d'établissement donc il ne peut pas
choisir son équipe il ne peut pas porter
un vrai projet pédagogique il le peut
beaucoup plus dans le privé que dans le
public d'ailleurs on devrait s'inspirer
parfois des recet du privé donc c'est
c'est tout cela qu'il faut mettre en
place juste pour terminer avec le
remanement le gouvernement et
l'éducation nationale Amélie ou Castera
elle peut rester au gouvernement pour
vous moi j'aime pas critiquer les
personnes je veux pas rentrer là-dedans
ça c'est leur problème mais là s par de
la personne on parle de déclaration
politique est-ce qu'elle est pas une
ministre empêché aujourd'hui à
l'éducation elle a énormément de
difficultés mais jeallis dire ça c'est
leur problème à eux moi je veux pas
vraiment pas rentrer pour moi la vraie
question c'est comment on fait pour que
nos enfants sachent lire écrire en
arrivant en 6e pour qu'ils aient un
niveau d'empathie également j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des cours d'empathie mais
l'empathie c'est pas que ça c'est une
question aussi d'intellect comment on
fait pour qu'on a des enf enfant qui soi
capable en effet de débattre quand ils
sont plus grands mais parce qu'ils ont
acquis les outils de la réflexion parce
qu'ils sont meilleurs en grammaire parce
qu'ils sont meilleurs en mathématiques
c'est toute ces questions là qu'il faut
résoudre c'est pas des questions de
casting avec Madame ou ctera ou je sais
pas qui une question sur les les
européennes vous avez quitté les
républicains en 2019 pour suivre Valérie
PCR chez libre quel loit est ce que vous
soutenez aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
ferez campagne pour la liste qui sera
conduite par François Xavier bami aux
européennes alors je ferai campagne pour
François Xavier bami an Sander je enfin
je ne sais pas qui sera sur la liste
mais en tous les cas
ça c'est le parti qui décide
mais avoir une idée quand même ben même
pas je vais pas vous mentir je nai
aucune idée de j'imagine non j'imagine
que ça va être dans les dans les jours
qui viennent mais la vraie question
d'ailleurs ça va ça va interroger un
petit peu d'ailleurs le rapport à la
politique qu'on a aujourd'hui qui on
veut voir élu aujourd'hui des amateurs
des gens qui répondre à des castings
politiques ou des gens qui ont bossé je
suis dans un parti politique qui arrête
pas de parler du Mérite est-ce que les
les gens qu'on a élu au Parlement
européen ont été méritants bah oui ils
ont bossé ils ont un bilan ouais alors
écoutez moi je suis pas là pour faire la
maîtresse d'école en tous les cas la
tête de l'IS François xéer bami ah il y
a pas de doute ah j'ai aucun doute sur
le fait qu'il a travaillé mais
d'ailleurs honnêtement même ses
adversaires politiqu qui on le
reconnaissent donc déjà qu'on é des gens
sérieux des gens qui siègent au
Parlement bon je pensais à Monsieur
Bardella même à la région vous savez
comment l'appelle onappelle B des Palas
il n'est jamais là il ne vient pas à la
région il siè à peine au Parlement
européen la politique c'est quelque
chose de sérieux on voit ce qui se passe
avec les agriculteurs c'est des
questions qui sont aussi essentiellement
d'ordre européen pour ça il faut avoir
une constance il vaut avoir une pourquoi
avoir autant tardé pour lancer François
Xavier bamide dans la campagne s'il y
avait une je crois j'ai été la première
à me répondre sur les réseaux sociaux
pour demander àce qu'il soit rapidement
nommé tête de liste parce il a été trop
tard non il a pas été trop tard parce
que quand on regarde par rapport aux
autres partis politiques c'est quand
même arrivé dans dans la même fourchette
de temps je crois qu'il y en a même qui
n'ont pas avant dernier il manque plus
que la majorité présidentielle bah vous
voyez non non je pense qu'il a été nommé
à temps puis surtout il est prêt il est
prêt parce que ça il a
travaillé n'est pas un amateur
contrairement à ce que disait monsieur
Macron de son équipe il avait dit soyez
fier d'être des amateurs ben moi je suis
fière d'être avec des gens qui sont des
travailleurs est-ce que ces élections
c'est un peu kitouou pour votre parti
est-ce que ça peut être l'élection de la
dernière chance je P je ne pense pas
sincèrement parce que l'avantage de
l'élection européenne c'est que c'est
quand même des débats qui parfois
d'ailleurs sont assez techniques et qui
permettent justement de montrer qui a du
fond et qui n'en a pas donc je suis
assez confiant
sur la présidentielle Stéphane alors je
pense que vous avez vu que Xavier
Bertrand avait annoncé qu' son attention
d'être candidat à la présidentielle
dimanche dans dimanche ouest-fance vous
avez été porte-parole du candidat
François Fillon à la présidentielle de
2017 porte-parole de la candidate
Valérie pcress à la présidentielle de
2021 serez-vous la porte-parole du
candidat Xavier Bertrand à la
présidentielle de 2027 alors écoutez
c'est je ne regrette absolument pas mes
choix je sais que la mode est de cracher
dans la sou moi c'est pas du tout mon
cas je suis fière d'avoir soutenu des
personnes qui étaient qualifié
intellectuellement et pour qui j'ai
l'estime personnel en revanche j'ai
passé là j'ai le temps d'être
porte-parole des autres et c'est pour ça
que j'ai écrit un livre pour être ma
propre porte-parole mais mais ça veut
dire quoi juste que vous avez envie
d'être autre chose qu'une porte-parole
est-ce que vous pourriez être candidate
à la présidentielle en tous les cas moi
j'ai envie de faire porter mes idées
même au moment d'une primaire si une
primaire à droite ou j'en ai écoutez
c'est c'est bien de de servir son parti
politique c'est bien de servir ses idées
à travers d'autres mais un moment on n
jamais si bien servi que par soi-même
moi les questions que je développe dans
mon livre je n'ai pas l'impression
qu'ell soit portée aujourd'hui
autant que moi par la droite
républicaine ça ne veut pas dire que mes
amis n'ont pas des des idées qui sont
aussi très intéressantes donc comme
Xavier Bertrand vous avez envie d'y
aller vous en 2027 non j'ai pas
forcément envie d'y aller ce que j'ai
envie c'est en tous les cas ne plus être
accaparé à servir la parole de quelqu'un
même si j'ai énormément d'estime pour
les uns et les autres mais de prendre du
temps pour développer les les idées oui
mais si vous dites que vos idées ne sont
pas représentées dans vot partie ça veut
dire que vous vous avez envie de les
porter et jusqu'au bout on imagine je
verrai juste vous venez d'utiliser
excusez-moi vous venez d'utiliser un un
un gros mot concernant la la
présidentielle vous avez parlé primaire
ah
oui disait notre ami Philippe Juvin dès
qu'on dit le mot prima tout le monde se
met à convulser mais je moi je pense
quand même qu'il peut y avoir une
candidate ou un candidat naturel j'ai
encore cette espérance néanmoins bah on
verra on est à 3 ans des élections
président cétait censé être renvoquer
visiblement ça allit pas écoutez euh il
me semble que si on prend l'exemple de
Monsieur Macron ça s'est révélé assez
tard mais si on y arrive pas et ben ou
faudra bien départager ça alors on va
éviter de dire le mot primaire parce que
dès qu'on dit le mot primaire tout le
monde se met à à trembler mais n'empêche
pour départager les gens faudra bien
trouver un système parce que il n'y a
pas de raison que ce soit l'un ou
l'autre ou l'une ou l'autre si on arrive
pas à avoir de candidat ou de candidates
naturell donc les primaires sont pas
entéré est-ce que vous serez en mesure
déjà d'avoir un candidat LR ou est-ce
que face à l'extrême droite et face à
l'extrême gauche il faudra un candidat
du bloc central c'est-à-dire LR plus
majorité présidentielle je pense que le
drame aujourd'hui depuis d'ailleurs pas
mal de temp temp c'est qu'on se situe
toujours par rapport aux autres
c'est-à-dire comment je prends un petit
peu à l'extrême droite comment je prends
un petit peu à l'extrême centre et
cetera on fait une tambouille une espèce
de cocktail d'ailleurs assez indigeste
la la pour moi si on a une vision claire
si on apporte de nouveau de l'espérence
au pays si on donne aux gens la l'envie
d'aller vers l'avant mais je pense qu'il
y aura pas besoin de se dire est-ce que
je vais assez sur ma gauche ou est-ce
que je vais asseer sur ma droite il faut
déjà savoir qui on est et pour ça il y a
un travail un agend Mau déjà important à
faire peut-être aussi un droit
d'inventaire sur ce qu'on a raté ou pas
d'ailleurs moi c'est ce que je me
permets de faire et et en même temps
proposer autre chose on pourra on ne
pourra pas aller vers le peuple on est
coupé des classes populaires on ne
pourra pas aller vers le peuple
uniquement avec des mesures qui sont en
fait des mesures qui sont en fait des
moyens la réduction de la dette
évidemment c'est hyper important mais la
réduction de la dette c'est un moyen
réguler les flux migratoires c'est hyper
important mais c'est un moyen quelle est
la vision pour mon pays quelle est la
vision pour réconcilier la France quelle
est ma vision pour ut contre les
fractures sociales mais sauf qu'on
entend ça che chez les républicains
Florence Portell depuis que Nicolas
Sarkozi a quitté le pouvoir ça fait 12
ans écoutez ça fait même depuis Nicolas
Sarkozi moi à chaque fois que j'ai vu un
programme et même un programme tout à
fait admirable he à chaque fois c'est
réduction de la det peine planché
immigration enfin on trouve toujours les
mêmes choses qui sont d'ailleurs
essentielles encore une fois attention
je ne critique pas mais ça c'est du
niveau d'un Premier ministre c'est pas
du niveau d'un président de la
République d'ailleurs on ne parle plus
de politique étrangère alors je parle
même pas du récipient d'air actuel de du
55 rue du Faubourg Saint-Honoré qui lui
n'a jamais eu de stratégie diplomatique
moi je ne sais pas quelle est la vision
diplomatique de parti qui en 12 ans n'a
toujours pas trouvé une ligne et n'est
toujours pas audible est encore un parti
de
gouvernement je pose la question pour
les non je pense que c'est quand même
par éout je pense sincèrement qu'on est
un parti de gouvernement parce qu'encore
une fois ce que je vous dis c'est que on
est prêt à être installé au manettes de
Matignon on est prêt B la présidentielle
c'est autre chose comment porte la
France comme grande puissance dans le
monde
d'aujourd'hui comment on réconcilie des
territoires fracturés comment on donne
au vie aussi envie aux générations de de
vivre ensemble comment on recrée de la
fraternité dans notre pays bon ça je
suis désolée c'est pas des mesures
technocratique ça demande une élévation
une vision et moi je pense que les gens
ont besoin d'élévation et pas uniquement
de mesures importantes mais qui relève
d'un programme gouvernemental mais pas
d'un programme présidentiel mais est-ce
que vous avez échoué à le faire ces
dernières années en république tout à
fait la faute à qui bah la faute à tout
le monde la faute à tout le monde c'est
on a des gens qui se sont présentés aux
élections présidentielles qui étaient
d'une très très grande qualité
intellectuelle qui ont présenté des
programmes avec beaucoup de t ils ont eu
deres difficultés hein les cœurs à la
droite l'état de de faiblesse aussi des
des partis politiques et cetera mais je
pense sincèrement qu'on doit porter un
discours qui élève la nation et pas
simplement une série de mesures
techniques un mot sur l'IVG puisque ça
va être un débat ici au Sénat à la fin
du mois et c'est un débat au sein de
votre parti est-ce que vous comprenez
que les sénateurs les républicains
Gérard Larché Bruno rotillot en tête
s'oppose à inscrire l'IVG dans la
Constitution alors je le présenterai pas
comme ça moi je vais vous dire en tous
les cas ma ma position
oui l'inscription d'bg dans la
Constitution pourquoi pas mais alors je
vais vous dire pourquoi mais c'est parce
qu'à mon avis comme à chaque fois dans
ce pays on prend le débat à l'envers la
question c'est à quoi sert une
constitution et c'est vrai que le
constituent 1958 le constituant n'a pas
choisi de de faire une constitution
comme l'ont fait les allemands comme
l'ont fait les Américains comme l'ont
fait aussi des pays qui ont été
traumatisés par la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et qui ont inscrit en préambule
ou par voie d'amendement des grands
principes fondamentaux ou de ce qui
relève parfois du droit naturel bon nous
ça n'a pas été notre choix et d'ailleurs
ça a provoqué un coup d'état
constitutionnel juge constitutionnel
1971 où on a créé un bloc de
constitutionnalité en intégrant des
principes fondamentaux alors comme la
déclaration les droits de l'homme et des
citoyens et d'autres principes qui sont
peut-être un peu plus euh euh
discutables voilàqu non mais c'est pas
lesquel mais on a créé une jurisprudence
un peu comme ça de briquet de broc alors
très bien juge ça permet de de s'appuyer
dessus mais donc la question pour moi
c'est est-ce que finalement on
retravailler notre Constitution pour y
introduire des droits fondamentaux et
pourquoi pas c'est une question
d'ailleurs qui avait été posée en 2008 à
Simone veille elle avait dit non la même
Simon veille qui a fait la loi pour
l'avortement et dans ce cas-là si on y
dit oui pourquoi pas y inscrire l'IVG
mais d'autres droit fondamentaux
également ou alors est-ce que l'on
considère que notre Constitution ne sert
pas à ça mais ça c'est un débat sur la
vous la Constitution c'est pas un
catalogue de droits sociau et sociétaux
non je dis aujourd'hui la Constitution
ce n'est pas ça mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas constitution non al moi si
j'étais présidente de la République il y
a deux choses que je ferais au niveau de
la Constitution un je réunirai des
constitutionnalistes et puis les
présidents des chambres et cetera pour
faire un débat justement sur qu'est-ce
qu'un grand texte fondamental et aussi
qu'est-ce qu'un conseil constitutionnel
qu'est-ce qu'une cour suprême c'est un
vrai sujet et la deuxième chose que je
réformerais c'est le référendum si
c'était possible et si j'avais la
majorité pour là est-ce que vous
voteriez l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution àure Act sincèrement je ne
sais pas à cause des raisons que je vous
ai dites je pense que c'est apparment
l'expression un piège à con parce que la
difficulté c'est que si vous partez dans
une posture un peu si vous vous élevez
dans le débat en disant bah voilà le
problème c'est que la Constitution
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi ce serait que
l'IVG et cetera on va vous dire c'est
vraiment dégueulasse vous êtes contre
l'avortement alors qu'en plus la droite
n'a pas de leçon à recevoir la p c'est
nous l'ivgc nous et cetera et du coup
vous allez tenté de dire bon je peux
quand même pas être taxé
d'anti-avortement parce que moi
personnellement je suis très féministe
et donc je vais être obligé de voter
pour inscription et c'est ça qui me gêne
et c'est ça qui me gêne dans le débat
actuel dans ce vide actuel c'est qu'on
se sent obligé d'avoir une position
parce que sinon on est catalogué alors
que la vraie question c'est à quoi sert
une constitution et à quoi sert une cour
suprême on va parler de la crise
agricole Stéphane oui est-ce que Gabriel
Attal a bien géré cette crise de votre
point de vue sincèrement plutôt plutôt
oui plutôt oui oui il a plutôt bien géré
la crise mais il a plutôt bien géré la
crise provoquée par son gouvernement
enfin ses gouvernements précédents
auquel d'ailleurs il a appartenu il a
pas cédé un peu beaucoup dans l'histoire
est-ce qu'il a eu raison de mettre en
pause le plan écopito par exemple
écoutez ce qui est terrible pour les
agriculteurs c'est VO c'est ce qui me
frappe avec les agriculteurs les gilets
jaunes et tous les toutes les personnes
qui dans ce pays toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles qui sont en en
détresse c'est en fait finalement le
profond sentiment d'injustice et la
difficulté c'est que on impose une série
de normes on impose un un dictat de
norme dans ce pays qui fait que il y a
une incompréhension sur les objectifs
qui sont poursuivis on n'accompagne pas
les gens vers ça même sur l'écologie moi
je suis vraiment pour porter des mesures
fortes en matière d'écologie mais je
dirais un peu comme il y a un
consentement à à l'impôt il faudrait un
consentement aux mesures écologiques il
faut accompagner les les les gens vers
ça euh m vous l'écrivez dans dans votre
livre dans Fran parler vous dites la
transition écologique ne se fera pas
sans le monde rural oui tout à fait mais
c'est précisément ce qu'on dit les
écologistes pendant la crise non non non
attendez les écologistes est-ce qu'ils
se sont battus pour la souveraineté
est-ce que les écologistes se sont
battus pour la souveraineté alimentaire
est-ce qu'ils se sont battus pour qu'on
limite les importations estce qu'ils se
sont battu pour ça ce qu'ils ont défendu
nos agriculteurs non donc la première
vraie mesure écologique c'est de se
battre pour la souveraineté alimentaire
ce qu' n'ont absolument pas fait et ce
que n'a pas fait non plus d'ailleurs
Renaissance au Parlement européen et
vous dites une politique de droite c'est
à mon sens une politique de la
souveraineté alimentaire est-ce que ça
veut dire que les républicains doivent
voter l'inscription de la souveraineté
alimentaire dans la loi comme le demande
Gabriel oui mais la question c'est pas
de voter la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aussi au niveau du
Parlement européen c'est pour ça que je
vous disais faut pas élir des amateurs
mais des gens sérieux Renaissance par
exemple sur les accords de libre échange
avec les pays de l'Amérique du Sud a eu
des positions complètement contraires au
Parlement européen à droite il y a une
ligne claire donc c'est pour ça moi
j'appelle vraiment les gens à regarder
dans le détail c'est sympa les slogans
ça fait plaisir moi aussi je peux vous
faire des petites musiques de droite je
vais dans une réunion publique de
militants LR je sais exactement ce qu'il
faut dire pour me faire applaudir c'est
ce que fait d'ailleurs Gabriel hatal
mais derrière c'est quoi le fond
d'ailleurs on a un député qui a fait
parmi d'autres un excellent travail
c'est Julien div moi je suis Fiè d'avoir
des gens comme Julien DIV ou comme
Philippe Juvin à la santé c'est des gens
qui font des vraies propositions et le
Livre blanc de sur l'agriculture DLR on
en on a pas en rougir il y a des vraies
proposition dedans sur la question du
logement Stéphan oui vous vous l'avez
évoqué en au début au début de de de
l'entretien euh le mais moi j'ai j'ai
noté que dans dans frarler vous vous
disiez que le votre livre la droite à
pêché en abandonant au pouvoirs tout au
CLA sur la politique du logement donc ça
c'est un sujet qui vous tient à cœur
Gabriel a fait quand même quelques
annonces sur dans son discours de
politique générale notamment une qui a
fait bondir la possibilité de déroger au
principe de la loi su solidarité et
renouvellement urbain pour placer des
ménages intermédiaire non non alors
vousz dans votre livreaband bien sûr
bien sûr mais alors en plus je construis
du logement social c'est uniquement
parce qu'elle est inapplicable et
qu'elle est complètement stupide je vous
donne un exemple j'ai un collègue qui
est le maire de Franconville qui qui a
cheval sur ces questions là aussi qui
nous expliquait que s'il appliquait
strictement la loi SRU où à chaque fois
on réinjecte du logement social dès
qu'on construit donc on doit remettre un
quota ça marche au pourcentage il aurait
pas loin de la densité de Bombet s'il
devait vraiment appliquer strictement la
loi SRU donc c'est complètement dément
et je vous passe des collègues qui sont
en prise avec des injonctions cfcayennes
de l'État ma collègue d'over suroise où
quand elle elle est carencée puis quand
elle veut construire vous avez le
ministère de la Culture qui vous lui dit
ah oui mais pas là donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué mais de de manière
globale pourquoi je suis pas d'accord
avec ce que vous dites sur ce qu' dit
Gabriel Atal un déjà il a dit quelque
chose qui dans la pratique est Faou il a
dit il faut remettre au maire le ça
c'est une proposition pouvoir
d'attribution des du premier peuplement
des premiers en réalité c'est déjà le
cas dans la pratique c'est après qu'on a
plus la main à quelques exceptions près
donc c'est pas ça le problème la
deuxième difficulté c'est que quand on
dit on va mettre du logement
intermédiaire dans le Côa logement
social c'est actuellement le cas par
exemple des BRS où on sépare vous savez
c'est c'est des logements sociaux vous
séparez l'achat du du foncier et du bâti
bon et ce qui permet en plus de d'être
comment assujti à une TVA extrêmement
réduite à 55 et payer beaucoup moins
cher le les murs du logement que vous
vous allez acquérir bon il y a le BRS il
y a le PSLA qui a un moyen de d'accéder
à du logement de mettre de l'épargne de
côté pour vraiment très schématiser et
au bout de de 2 ans vous pouvez
commencer à ressortir cette épargne et
devenir propriétaire ça alors ça le bsla
c'est inclu dans le logement social
seulement pendant 2 ans bon la
difficulté c'est les dispositifs qui
sont en fait de l'accession moyenne à la
propriété
déguisé c'est qu'en fait c'est dans le
logement social dans ce qu'on appelle
les pls alors pardon d'être aussi
technique mais il y a
TR ça fait
TRR je vous explique il y a du tras
social il y a du Moyen social et il y a
du social plus voilà le social plus
c'est le pls quand vous êtes carencé
vous n'avez droit qu'à un/ers de ce
logement social plus les accessions à la
propriété ses d'accession sociale à la
propriété que décrit Gabriel Atal ce ça
va être compris dans un quotat d'un
tiers des logements sociaux ce que je
suis en train de vous dire c'est qu'en
fait ce qu'il raconte ça veut dire qu'il
connaît pas ses propr croyez pas mais
non c'est j'y crois pas c'est qu'en fait
c'est inapplicable en fait il faudrait
que réellement on déverrouille la loi
SRU mais qu'on ait aussi des
propositions en matière de chaîne du
logement la difficulté aussi aujourd'hui
c'est que vous ne pouvez pas être
propriétaire à cause des prêts immobiles
à cause des taux à cause des difficultés
pour les banques à donner des crédits
donc en réalité c'est tout l'ensemble
qu'il faut revoir c'est aussi la
difficulté pour les mares de faire
construire on ne peut pas construire
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est complètement
bloqué moi j'ai des recours tous les
jours par les écologistes dès que je
construis et c'est les mêmes qui me
disent de construire du logement social
mais tout à l'heure vous me disiez il y
a beaucoup d'acronymes mais le diable
son j'en les détails et Gabriel Atal ce
qu'il a dit c'est du vent parce qu'en
réalité le logement social c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça parce
qu'on rentre à chaque fois dans des
petites niches qui vous enferment
complètement et ça il n'en a pas pas
parler parce qu'en fait il n'y connaî
rien sur le logement social il n'y a
jamais eu de politique d'État de la part
de d'Emmanuel Macron j'allis dire de
Gabriel Macron sur le logement et ça
c'est vu on a eu régulièrement des
périodes depuis que Monsieur Macron est
élu sans ministre du Logement un un mot
sur la votation qui a eu lieu dimanche à
Paris pour tripler le prix du
stationnement des SUV vous qui êtes
maire d'une ville de banlieu qu'en
pensez-vous que quelqu'un fasse quelque
chose je je ne sais pas qui qui près de
qui il faut intercéder pour qu'elle
entende les le cri des banliusin me
rappelle margarette satcher qui avait
viré alors comparé hiidalgo à satcher
c'est quand même terrible mais qui avait
viré quand même les les familles de
Londres comme ça c'est une sorte de
ségrégation d'ailleurs sociale
absolument écœurante c'est une mesure
antifamille pour mais évidemment que
c'est mesur qui a des SUV puis attendez
c'est quoi les SUV moi par exemple il y
a pas très longtemps avec mon mari on a
changé nos voitures on a une hybride
rechargeable et une électrique mais en
fait finalement on va être pénalisé
parce que elles sont plus écolos mais
elles pèent plus lourd mais c'est
complètement idiot alors en réalité on
c'est très bien qu' ESS de renflouer les
caisses de la Mairie de Paris qu'elle a
copieusement vidé mais en plus il y a de
l'idéologie antibanlieu et le problème
c'est que la banlieu c'est pas les
riches je pour une socialiste c'est
quand même incroyable d'avoir une
politique anti Bonlieu et une politique
en effet antif famille parce que plus
votre véhicule est grand qu'à priori
vous avez des gosses et un IV c'est pas
forcément un 44 donc c'est ridicule puis
je vous passe quand même le fait que là
vous avez une participation de 5 et
quelques pour alors il vous dit mais
c'est merveilleux il y a une majorité de
oui à 55 % et pour la même raison d'une
faible participation mais avec un à 88 %
pour une une voix réservée sur le P
périphérique elle vous dit je ne
l'appliquerai pas je c'est quoi la
démocratie chez cette dame qu'il y a
même un bureau de vote où il y avait 108
% de participation je veux dire
franchement c'est du grand guignol le
problème c'est qu'elle fait beaucoup de
mal à Paris qui est la capitale de la
France moi j'ai honte j'ai honte parce
que Paris c'est aussi la lumière du
monde c'est aussi notre patrimoine et
cette dame le détruit copieusement une
dernière question Stéphane une question
d'actualité sur le les violences faites
aux élus aujourd'hui et demain
l'assemblée examine en séance publique
la proposition renforçant la sécurité
des élus locaux et la protection des
maires c'est un texte qui avait été
adopté en première lecture au Sénat moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que ce que vous en
pensez en tant que vice-présidente de la
MF d'association des Mair de France
alors nous on se bat énormément pour
cela évidemment c'est une bonne chose
c'est un bon texte c'est un bon texte
après je pense qu'il faudrait aussi
parler de notre mandat de manière
positive évidemment on a des collègues
qui connaissent des difficultés et
moi-même j'en ai parfois connu mais je
vous dirais qu'on a une chance
incroyable d'être élu de la République
d'être au service de nos concitoyens et
parfois il faudrait aussi pouvoir le
rappeler moi en tous les cas je ne me
sens pas victime je ne me sens pas
euh victime de mon mandat si je puis
dire je suis très fière d'avoir été
choisi par mes concitoyens je suis très
fière d'être au service de mon pays et
je suis très fière d'être maire de
France merci Florence Portelli merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité on
rappelle le titre de votre livre Fran
parler c'est aux éditions du SER et on
regarde la Une de wouest France qui va
sans doute vous intéresser ce sont ces
communes qui n'arrivent plus à s'assurer
une commune sur 10 n'arrive plus à
s'assurer et on a un entretien on a un
entretien avec anidalgo aussi qui va
vous
intéresser en West France merci beaucoup
on pass au club de teritire